a nurse who worked at the Arizona
healthcare facility where a severely and
capacitated patient was raped and
impregnated as revealing new details
about the facility a 36 year old man
charged with sexually assaulting the
woman will appear in court later today
nathan sutherland worked at hacienda
healthcare in phoenix until his arrest
last week Omar Villafranca is in Phoenix
outside the Maricopa County Courthouse
Omar good morning good morning nathan
sutherland is in the Maricopa County
Jail but we do expect to see him later
on this morning when he heads into court
now police say Sutherland who was a
nurse raped the 29 year old patient he
was in charge of caring for at Hacienda
Healthcare and got her pregnant now
Sutherlands attorney says his client has
entered not guilty pleas and they plan
to do their own DNA tests now last night
we spoke with another nurse who worked
at Hacienda back in 2016 Vera gist OVA
told us that she started seeing some
signs that were a little bit concerning
to her she left Hacienda after less than
a year frustrated with management and
how they were training their workers is
it safe to say you were basically
trained how to protect yourself but not
really treat for a patient correct and
how not to good Hacienda health care
sued that was a big thing that was a
huge thing just over says she didn't
know Sutherland or the patient he's
accused of sexually assaulting and we
also reached out to Hacienda about some
of her claims and they didn't
immediately get back to us hacienda has
said it's reviewing and trying to
improve the vetting process for its
caregivers no meanwhile advocate
advocates for people with developmental
disabilities are also basically trying
to put forth new laws with the state
legislature including training people to
spot sexual abuse and also stricter
rules for failing to
John alright Omar thank you